cuando estamos entrando en el cuarto mes
de guerra nuclear y estas son las
escenas que se ven en hardcore la
segunda ciudad de ucrania y la que ha
sido junto con mario por tal vez más
asediada y atacada durante estas semanas
de guerra vemos cierta normalidad porque
la presión que han ejercido las tropas
ucranianas contra las fuerzas rusas en
las afueras de esta ciudad ha logrado
que la presión que los ataques de
artillería sean menores esto se ve
reflejado en que por ejemplo las
autoridades locales están poniendo
presión y le piden a la población que
llevaba meses durmiendo en el metro
buscando refugio que se retire que si no
tienen donde ir están habilitando campos
de universidades o algunos colegios para
que puedan dormir pero la idea es que la
ciudad pueda ir recuperando poco a poco
la normalidad del metro es el medio de
transporte más seguro para la población
sigan habiendo ataques anoche solo
sonaron las alarmas hubo al menos dos
ataques que sentimos así que la
situación sigue siendo inestable pero
poco a poco también personas y familias
han regresado a la ciudad por la
situación económica porque más tranquilo
algunos locales han ido habiéndose
abriendo sin embargo obviamente la
situación no está totalmente controlada
hay inestabilidad hay incertidumbre por
lo que pueda pasar en el futuro pero aún
así en esta manera de sobrevivir a las
guerras las personas vuelven e intentan
rehacer su vida